everyone's talking about the the the
girl with uh munchkins disease what's it
called Munch Munch munchkin Munch by
proxy everyone talking about that girl
turns you into OA Loompa yeah exact over
time turns into a blue ball and flies
away
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah did you guys hear about the sex
tapes that were filmed of prince Andrew
Bill Clinton yes Richard Branson
according to an Epstein victim whoa and
the FBI is supposed to have video and
audio recordings but for some reason
everyone's focused on this list that's
not even a [__] list it's a
disposition and then they don't even
show the footage oh the deposition oh
yeah it's a disposition sorry you're
right thank you one person here one
person's a dancer one person is an
acclaimed
historian not Richard
Branson yeah he was out there like he's
a virgin I like them so Sarah Ransom I
believe I nailed that um she says three
men these three men were filmed by
Jeffrey Epstein which has been denied by
prince Andrew but he like I think he's
gotten pretty wrecked from denying a lot
of things so far um but Richard Branson
this is the first time I've heard his
name yeah for real that's a new one for
all the talk about like the the list
isn't a list it's just a
disposition God damn it he's never going
to let you live down no he's not going
to let me alone
[__] it's like when I used to hold the
computer like this the Branson name is
is new though it's actually new so the
Branson thing is new it's new that I've
seen he has had no response he hasn't
said well his team it he dened it his PR
team has been quick he's like I have a
plane yeah yeah I don't I have my own
Island what is the uh uh context exactly
about the Richard Branson it came out
later right that he was in one of these
tapes with Bill Clinton and and prince
Andrew and apparently together
apparently they might be in the same
video at the same time basically I think
it was this lady I think this lady is
talking about her friend or something
right this girl talking about her friend
who was a minor or something like that
that had to have sex with all of them so
basically they get like passed around
when they're like on the island and
stuff so she like apparently got down
with all three of these dudes and then
Epstein filmed it but was Sten Hawking
there at the underage that is the bigger
conversation that I'm excited to have
guys we I can't wait to talk about and
we are going to have it okay just not
right now okay we're going to do a whole
video about that one oh we're going to
dedicate one just for him all it
deserves one well cuz one guy requested
we do a whole video about it so we Nick
that is I did request it it was me we
never deny Nick's request I understand
like the whole you know like due
diligence build the case all that but
then I'm like [__] when you have videos
of [__] I wish they it didn't take so
long to just prosecute and execute on it
cuz it feels like oh cool we got we got
footage of this guy assassinating the
president don't worry in 3 years guys
we're going to finally get
we build to take so goddamn long you
think though like between like the
collaboration between mainstream media
and like the judge Judiciary System
everybody's like this is a big one so
let's milk it so we all get paid for
long oh yeah that too that too that
happens yeah our ratings are so [__]
right now end this right now but no no
no no no we got to hold on to this one
because everybody's going to get paid
this stories for days I always forget
that people do that [__] but what I'm
surprised about is that like it's
actually not bigger you know like it's
not being covered in a way bigger way or
people caring more and demanding more
yeah and it's more it's covered more on
Independent internet media than it is on
like CNN MSNBC why the [__] are you just
covering only this when it's like we're
all at War and [__] you know what I mean
there're supposed to be bigger stories
right they've done a good job of meing
this one too right even like the Epi
didn't kill himself stuff that sort of
has become like a meme it's sort of just
like a funny thing now but it's
nonchalant like people just throw it in
passing comedians just throw it out and
passing news aners everything like that
and people wear shirts with that and
like it so it turned into like a
different thing than like the
seriousness of what this actually was
about it kind of became this like silly
thing which is it's crazy how well that
[__] works right cuz we even play into
that stuff like you know can't help it
cuz it's like Epstein didn't kill
himself if we say that a bunch maybe
that something will happen and it
becomes silly it's almost more useful as
a joke that it is like a truth and and I
mean dude it's one of the craziest
things ever the cameras are dead oopsy
daisies yeah and everyone's asleep it's
so perfect yeah it's like you know and
somehow the guards that were on watch
that day all have brand new houses now
oh dude and Bill bar who was the AG at
the time he's like I checked it out
myself it's all good it's like he wrote
that in his book it's crazy um so yeah
then they there there's um she also the
same person says that um Trump was
involved he lik to suck on on chick's
nipples pretty good apparently he like
to bite them wrong actually written in
there written in here that sounds like a
Steve Green original
too a nipple L yeah she said that she ow
bite nipples huh she said that her
friend ouch right had um sexual
relations with Trump at jeffy's New York
mansion on regular occasions oh she said
that she had her friend had sexual
intercourse with Clinton Prince Andrew
Richard Branson and the the the the sex
tapes were filmed by Jeffrey but then
the Trump thing was another thing in
addition to damn all of them's going to
get [__] up huh her track Rec is kind
of badass right I mean if there's
something positive to say potentially
right Nick her body her body counts kind
of sick yeah for an underage girl that's
pretty good is that what you telling me
dude is that what you're trying to tell
me to say on camera is that what you're
saying that's true don't bring my
[__]
crew your license disposition don't dis
me that's like you know how many Nobel
Peace Prize winners I [__] it's like
that it's pretty crazy bad we say like
that stepen hawy no wrestling yeah I
think so so that's why remember like I
was seeing all this stuff about Trump's
on the list no he's not yes he is and
it's like people are focusing on that he
didn't go to the island but you're
saying that the stuff with Trump
happened not on the island but in New
York it's almost like you can [__] when
you're not on the island you don't have
to go there yeah yeah it's weird right
she's like I have my out I I've got my
Al he had uh aside from the island he
had the new y Island he had the New York
and the Florida residents that were
rigged with cameras and in the New York
one when the FBI raided and all that
[__] they found hella like hidden camera
and hella tapes all that stuff so that's
what they're saying they have footage of
like all these people [__] well the
idea the release them theidea behind it
is yes the idea behind it is that they
were using that blackmail to influence
politicians and control them basically
it's like Westworld but like for real
mhm so are we hopeless or what we just
got to be like up we found we saw a
little crack behind the curtain and then
ah [__] it I think it's going to be
difficult to get them while they're in
power but what's probably going to
happen is all this stuff will be
released after they die or um we have to
see a major Revolution but that's
probably not going to happen yeah that
[__] won't be fun though like imagine
they're like even [__] 95 years old
and they don't really care and then like
one week before they're going to pass
out anyway you know what I mean it's
like oh here's your tape and they're
like oh [__] look at that [__] yeah cuz
till this day till this day we don't
know what happened to we don't know what
happened to JFK either we still don't
know bro you think about like how long
it took them to Pop R Kelly and he's
he's R Kelly he's not even like a he
wasn't even hiding it he wasn't fighting
anything yeah they had like video they
had videotape they video evidence they
had like so many different yeah kids on
top of that and like probably what
hundreds of women being like yo that
dude [__] me over and it still took
him like took forever and he's still
living it up dude but even then the only
come up of justice is like Netflix
documentaries or whatever the [__] right
and I feel like that's half the battle
it's it's all just the entertainment
dude Epstein got so many documentaries
though still nobody cares nobody cares
yeah wait until we see the prince
Andrew's doctor yeah everyone's talking
about the the the girl with uh munchkins
disease what's it called Munch Munch
munchin mun Munch by proxy everyone
talking about that girl but nobody
talking about Epstein turns you into oal
Loompa yeah EXA over time it's green
hair and orange skin turns into a blue
ball and flies away yeah I know the
disease I'm familiar I think if there is
a group trying to seize power in the
states like let's say there's like cuz
even if you look at it you can't look at
it as like just right wing and left wing
right there's like there's like
different Clicks in the right and the
left and then I think if there was a new
group coming up trying to come up if
they get into power they can probably
take out their opponents by using the
Epstein [__] by being like all right
[__] Clinton [__] this guy
whatever and it's like Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam and then now we can take power I
feel like they'll never get the clintons
bro nah I don't think so I don't think
so either dude cuz they're too innocent
Dude too like I didn't do [__] I didn't
do it you know his name was like like
over 50 times mentioned in it's like
he's been a oh man we all know he's the
number one Hound ever since he took that
photo squatting on the train tracks he's
Untouchable Untouchable dude this guy
every every person that works on Epstein
Island was like without a doubt Bill
Clinton was here I don't know about Bill
Gates but Bill Clinton was here all time
everyone who worked there even the Jan's
got a selfie with Bill Clinton and he's
he's like this he's like yo check
it when they see him they're like we're
going to get you he's like yeah
right that's my boy Bill dude yo hit him
with the stink dude he's on they can't
get him man we should probably delete
this video cuz don't people end up dead
when they talk about the clintons yeah
they do but we but we but we're giving
them props bro yeah we're giving you
guys props end up more life than ever
Bill Clint's going to watch the video
and be like those guys over there real
cool like Justin Timberlake movie for
the watch here we'll just say this just
hide the tapes keep them hidden right
we're good right show him don't ever
show him Epstein was I think he was
depressed think he had anxiety oh yeah
dude that's the worst he had social
anxiety so he had to kill
himself mental health is a big deal it's
a huge deal
man's [__] nobody talks about that
when it comes to this case by the way do
we need to check in with each other
again Nick he's just in the cell going
he's in the cell
like there's a really there's a really
good podcast with a guy that was locked
up in that same prison um and he was
explaining how the whole process works
with a double triple checks and he goes
there's no [__] way that the cameras
were off and someone was sleeping and he
goes like there's always someone that's
checking to make sure every hour by the
hour that someone's awake or checking
something so he's like the only way it
would have happened and then he has a
couple of theories of like someone
coming in at that moment or someone was
already planted there and then the doors
were magically open he's like there's
like couple of ways that it can happen
but not the way that you know we think
it is or the only other way is if there
was like a serious oopsy daisies yeah
and that's maybe what happened and he
was depressed I'm telling you man people
don't talk about that like epy knew
exactly the right time to kill himself
while the cameras were off he was sad
boy sundang too like I heard his team
wasn't doing so good he was really
wallowing in it he was doing bad in
fantasy oh [__] yeah dude he forgot a
set of flex this guy dude can you
believe
it he lost by he lost by one point to a
kicker forgot forgot he he he has his
kicker benched oh my God if it's fantasy
Stefon digs on the bench when he went
off that week he went off for 47 that
week God what a travesty DUS kidding
news careful voice is a brand just
kidding news is the man of smart people
the people of just kidding news careful
boys they are very smart just kiding
news the number one podcast in the
world